never hurts to get a lot of practice so
in this video i'm just going to do a
bunch more of essentially what we call
long division problems and so if you
have 4
goes into
and i don't know why exactly why they
call it long division and we were we saw
this in the last video a little bit i
didn't call it long division then but i
think the reason why is you could think
it takes you a long time or it takes a
it takes a long piece of your paper you
kind of as you go
along you kind of have this thing that
get this long tail that develops on the
problem so all of those are at least
reasons in my head why it's called long
division but we saw in the last video
there's a way to tackle any division
problem while just knowing your
multiplication tables up to maybe 10
times 10 or 12 times 12. just as a
better review this is the same thing as
divided by
4 and it's actually the same thing and
you probably haven't seen this notation
before as 2292
divided by
4. these this this and this are all
equivalent statements on some level and
as you can see you say hey sal that
looks like a fraction in case you have
seen fractions already and that is
exactly what it is it is a fraction but
anyway i'll just focus on this format
and in future videos we'll think about
other ways to represent division so
let's do this problem so 4 goes into 2
how many times it goes into no times so
let's move on to let me switch colors
let's move on to the 22 4 goes into 22
how many times let's see 4 times 5
4 times 5 is equal to 20.
4 times 6 is equal to 24
so 6 is too much so 4 goes into 22 5
times
5 times 4 is 20 there's going to be a
little bit of a leftover and then we
subtract
22 minus 20 well that's just 2
and then you bring down
this 9.
and you saw in the last video exactly
what this means right when you wrote
this 5 up here notice we were in the
hundreds place so this is really a 500
but in this video i'm just going to
focus more on the process and you can
think more about what it actually means
in terms of where i'm writing the
numbers but i think the process is going
to be crystal clear hopefully by the end
of this video so we brought down the
nine four goes into 29 how many times
see four it goes into at least six times
what's four times seven four times seven
is twenty-eight so it goes into it at
least seven times what's four times
eight
four times eight is 32 so it can't go
into it eight times so it's going to go
to seven
four goes into 29
seven times seven times four is
29 minus 28 to get our remainder for
this step in the problem
is one and now we're gonna bring down
this two
i'm gonna bring it down
and you get a twelve
4 goes into 12 that's easy 4 times 3 is
12. 4 goes into 12
3 times 3 times 4 is 12
12 minus 12 is 0 we have no remainder so
4 goes into 2 292 exactly 573 times so
this
2292 divided by 4 we can say is equal to
573 or we could say that this thing
right here
is equal to 573
let's do a couple more
let's do a few more problems
let me pick a nice do that red color so
say we had 7
going into six thousand
four hundred
and seventy-five maybe it's called long
division because you write it nice and
long up here and you have this line i
don't know uh there's multiple reasons
why it could be called long division so
you say seven goes into six zero times
so we need to keep moving forward so
seven so then we go to 64. seven goes
into 64. how many times let's see seven
seven times
seven is well that's way too small let
me think about a little bit well 7 times
9 is 63 that's pretty close and then 7
times 10 is going to be too big 7 times
10 is 70. so that's too big so 7 goes
into 64
9 times
9 times 7 is 63
64 minus 63 to get our remainder at this
stage is 1.
bring down the 7.
bring down the 7. 7 goes into 17 how
many times well 7 times 2 is 14 and then
7 times 3 is 21 so 3 is too big so 7
goes into 17 two times
2 times 7 is 14.
17 minus fourteen is three
and now we bring down the five
we bring down the five
and seven goes into thirty-five that's
in our seven multiplication tables five
times five times seven is thirty-five 5
times 5 times 7 is
35 and there you go and so the remainder
is 0. so all the examples i did so far
had no remainders let's do one that
maybe might have a remainder and to
ensure it has a remainder i'll just make
up the problem it's much easier to make
problems that have remainders than the
ones that don't have remainders
so let's say i want to divide 3
let's say i want to divide 3
into
i'm gonna divide it into
let's say
one seven three five
zero
nine
two this will be a nice beastly problem
so if we can do this we can handle
everything so there's one million seven
hundred thirty five thousand and ninety
two that's what we're dividing three
into
so
three goes actually i'm not sure if this
will have a remainder and in the future
video i'll show you whether
whether how to figure out whether
something is divisible by three actually
we can do it right now we just add up
all these digits one plus seven is eight
eight plus three is eleven eleven plus
five is sixteen
sixteen
plus nine
is 25 25 plus 2 is 27. so actually this
number is divisible by 3. so if you add
up all of the digits you get 27 and then
you can add up those digits 2 plus 7 is
9. so that is divisible by 9. that's a
trick that only works for three so this
number actually is divisible by three so
let me let me change it a little bit so
it's not divisible by three
let me put a let me make this into a
let me make this into a one
now this number will not be divisible by
three i definitely want a number where
i'll end up with a remainder just to
just so you see what it looks like
so let's do this one three goes into one
zero times so we can just move forward
you could write a zero here and multiply
that out and that just makes it a little
bit messy in my head so 3 so we just
move 1 to the right 3 goes into 17 how
many times well 3 times
is equal to 15 and 3 times 6 is equal to
18 and that's too big so 3 goes into 17
right here 5 times 5 times 3 is 15
and we subtract 17 minus 15
is
and now we bring down this 3
set 3 goes into 23 how many times well 3
times 7 is equal to 21 and 3 times 8 is
too big that's equal to 24. so 3 goes
into 23 seven times
seven times seven times three
is twenty one and we subtract twenty
three minus twenty one is
two
now we bring down the next number we
bring down the five i think you can
appreciate why it's called long division
now
we bring down
this five three goes into 25 how many
times well twenty three times eight gets
you pretty close and three times nine is
too big so it goes into it eight times
eight times three is twenty four i'm
going to run out of space you subtract
you get 1 25 minus 24 is 1.
now we can bring down this 0. you bring
down this 0 just like that
and you get 3 goes into 10 how many
times well that's easy goes into it
three times three times three is nine
that's about as close to 10 as we can
get three times three is nine
ten minus nine i'm going to have to
scroll up and down here a little bit ten
minus nine is one
and then we can bring down the next
number i'm running out of colors
i can bring down that nine
three goes into 19 how many times well
six is about as close as we can get that
goes to eighteen so three times six
three goes into 19 six times six times
three let me scroll down
six times three is eighteen
nineteen minus eighteen we subtract it
up here too 19 minus eighteen is one and
then we're almost done i can revert back
to the pink we bring down this one right
there and bring down that one three goes
into 11 how many times well that's three
times because three times four is too
big it's three uh three times four is
twelve so that's too big so it goes into
it three times so three goes into eleven
3 times 3 times 3
is 9
and then we subtract and we get a
2 and there's nothing left to bring down
right and when we look up here there's
nothing left to bring down so we're done
so we're left with a remainder of two
after doing this entire problem
so the answer three goes into one
million seven hundred thirty five
thousand and ninety one it goes into it
five hundred and seventy eight thousand
three hundred 363 remainder
and that remainder 2 is what we got
all the way down there so hopefully you
now appreciate that you can tackle
pretty much any division problem and you
also through this exercise can
appreciate why it's called long division